[Music]
Harry was lorem option here from
luekemia net I'm here with Dylan talk
about Eldon hasn't forgotten tell us a
little bit about Eldon yeah so that
would need a medieval eldritch fantasy
game it's based on like environmental
storytelling and reactive combat so one
of the things I like to say is it's kind
of entry like a book in a language you
don't understand but every other page is
a picture so yeah the whole stories talk
about any dialogue of words as a story
imagery and experiencing the game
wonderful wonderful tell us a little bit
about the art style that's going into
Elden though because it's a very unique
visual style yeah Cheers
sir actually started the game in
university so I study in game
development and I spent a long time just
trying to work out the art style it was
inspired by a few different things as a
game code crawl which you may have heard
of before but that's by a game company
called cow hoof so it's a little bit
inspired by that a little defied by
things like sword and sorcery but yeah
and then just saw with my own twist on
it so with this kind of game what came
first gameplays story or the art side
you had in mind game play
yeah well odd style gameplay that's very
yeah perfect well dad we talked about
gameplay I talked a little about what
what's going on screen here I wanna
break down ball players are looking at
yeah this is the start of the game the
game is actually kind of basically
inspired by my early childhood I moved
out of home when I was like 15 years old
and I was living by myself an apartment
so kind of just doing play the
tribulations of growing up and going to
adulthood passing all those barriers so
yeah at the moment players just come out
of the house and they've discovered that
their mother is missing she's
disappeared into some strange portal and
you're out to try and save her
perfect we're begging again kind of like
a super high fantasy lure the Rings vibe
Mavs on track with that or were you
leaning more towards so I like to call
it an eldritch fantasy so it's pretty
inspired by the works of like Lovecraft
and the secondary Lovecraft stuffs are
works inspired by Lovecraft but yeah
it's definitely got a bit of that high
fantasy because I'm just a sucker for
that kind of stuff it's more than
eldridge fantasy tentacles and the
unknown fear of the unknown
perfect perfect well how many people are
actually working on this game so it's
mainly me so impressive yeah it's a lot
of work initially we had like two other
people helping out on the project and I
my publisher does supply me a program
when I need a little bit of extra
assistance but yeah besides that I do
like so I do like all the pro I do most
programming all the art and I have
someone else doing it the audio for me
because it's one thing about do
programming and art but audio is a whole
other thing
yeah I'm sure I'm sure especially with
all the effects are going on and even
music I'm sure music plays a big role
too it's got like a dynamic music system
so the music is entwined with the actual
gameplay Wow so the music changes
depending on where you are and what
you're doing very well thank you so much
for a breakdown l didn't path and for
guide my key players expect to play it
expect to play it yeah so relatively
soon we don't have a hard day but you
can expect it pretty soon cool cool and
more platforms so basically everything's
I like PlayStation and Xbox which steam
and atomic Robert we'll keep an eye out
for that
that's right there L didn't pass the
four guy and think you didn't so much
for your time go look at nurses
development all right it's about lore
macho signing off and loads of gaming
net
[Music]